Mike let me start with LeSean McCoy the
end NFL has to wait for the police
report on all this LeSean McCoy news and
it could be a problem that that
investigation drags into the season if
he's on the field they're still
investigating him so what do we know
about this situation and where is it
headed with McCoy well here's one thing
to remember Dan in the aftermath of Ray
Rice nearly four years ago the NFL no
longer defers to the criminal justice
thora tease they'll do their own
investigation and if you have a
motivated victim like Ezekiel Elliott
had last year you can get cooperation
you can get information you can start
trying to piece this all together and by
the end of the day yesterday it appeared
that the very strong implication being
made by delecia cordons lawyers is that
LeSean McCoy arranged for someone to
invade the house he owns but she was
living in to retrieve jewelry that he
had given to her and through that
process she took a horrific beating
based upon the photographs that showed
up yesterday on social media so I don't
know if this thing breaks quickly or
slowly I don't know if the NFL makes
more progress than the authorities but
the theory seems to be fairly clear now
the question becomes whether or not the
evidence backs it up and obviously if
the evidence backs it up then this guy's
done but at this point it's just
allegations there is some circumstantial
evidence that's troubling but we see how
it all plays out but I think the NFL
will be looking into it along with the
authorities and it could be the NFL
provides some of its own resources to
help the authorities in Georgia push
this thing along much like the NFL did
with the authorities that were
investigating mike vick eleven years ago
had we heard from LeSean McCoy
well McCoy came out yesterday in the
immediate aftermath of the photos
emerging with the allegation that he
personally inflicted the injuries and he
said he hasn't been directly involved
with any of the individuals in months
and so okay if you haven't been around
these people you didn't do it but then
as it unfolded throughout the day it
appears that the argument will be if it
ever gets to this point that he arranged
for someone else to do it that's the
message that screams out from between
the lines of the statement that was
issued yesterday by the victim's lawyer
all right the purchase
for the Carolina Panthers is now
finalized but I guess they for 2.2 or
2.3 billion they also threw in jerry
richardson statue okay did the did the
new ownership want to take down the
stunt like was there a statute of
limitations here mike well you know the
owner said yesterday he's contractually
obligated to keep the statue which is
hardly a ringing endorsement when it
comes to the design well you know i have
to keep you know i have to keep it up
now it's possible there's some issue
with the city owning the land where the
statue is and maybe David Tepper
providing some cover for the city so
they don't start getting a bunch of
tough questions about why they'd allow
this statue to continue to stand but the
statue is going to continue to stand and
I'd hate to think that jerry richardson
could have gotten even more money for
the team but he gave up some of it so he
could secure the you know ongoing
placement of the statue well into the
future outside of the stadium why I
didn't even know there was a statue of
Jerry Richardson are there any other
statues of any other owners in the NFL I
don't think there are but you know what
this is probably given them all some
pretty good ideas well Jerry Jones Jerry
Jones suit statue of a guy in a suit
holding a football it's the strangest
thing nothing inspires you quite like
that you know when you show up at
Lambeau and you see Lombardi you know
Chicago Stadium with Jordan and then you
show up with the Carolina Panthers and
Jerry Richardson's there in a suit nice
yeah I agree with you Jerry Jones
probably probably already has the the
plans in place and it will be bigger and
nicer and more impressive than the Jerry
Richardson statue the NFL Players
Association had a statement yesterday
you know talking about the NFL's new
anthem policy why why did they wait so
long to put this statement out well
here's what they did they filed a
grievance and they waited until the
basically last minute they could file a
grievance under the collective
bargaining agreement cuz I think they've
been trying to work with the NFL behind
the scenes because this
not going to be a popular move right
anybody who is taking up the cause that
ultimately supports players not standing
for the anthem puts themselves in in the
the target zone for all of the criticism
whether it's from the president or
anyone else out there who insists that
the players should be standing so I
think the NFLPA was hoping to work it
out before they had to follow the
grievance now they've filed the
grievance and they plan to talk to the
NFL and that's what should have happened
back in August in 2016 I put a lot of
this on the NFL Dan they should have the
moment Colin Kaepernick was was seen
sitting during the national anthem in a
preseason game and the NFL told me I
said well hey what's your take on this
he said players are encouraged to stand
but not required this all comes from a
flawed policy the NFL wrote nine years
ago they should have engaged with the
Union to then to come up with a policy
that requires the players to stand they
didn't because I think they didn't want
to make a concession because if you ask
the Union hey we want something the
Union says we want something back that's
how it works
now that they've waited two years it's
gonna take a lot more I think to get the
the players to get in on that point than
it would have back in August of 2016
what would you suggest well if you were
mediating like advising the NFL how
would you handle this flag controversy
well I'd say hey NFL you have to engage
with the Union sit down at the
bargaining table and you want all the
players to agree to stand at attention
and respect the flag during the anthem
and you have to listen to what the Union
would want in return and I don't know at
this point what the Union would want in
return a lot of times people say well
get rid of the marijuana policy with the
Marijuana Policy it's a non-issue
because if you're smart you know how to
avoid a positive test I don't know that
the NFLPA is banging the drum to get rid
of that but maybe there's something the
NFLPA is looking for that you know it's
fairly significant and it's important to
them and this anthem policy is important
to the NFL and they could come up with
some sort of a quid pro quo a
give-and-take a back-and-forth to solve
this but I think the NFL's stubbornness
contributed to the problem in 2016 they
didn't want to give anything up to get a
commitment to stand and now that it's
going to cost even more to make it
happen they don't want to do it either I
just want
Ram it through the way that they choose
and and and if they have to fight they
have to fight but they could lose
because the arguments very simple dan
once this right exists the players have
the right to protest the nfo gave them
that right you can't just take it away
without sitting down and talking to the
Union that's the argument and it seems
pretty common sensical and if the Union
wins that then the policy gets rolled
back to what it was before May and the
NFL still has a major problem going into
the 2018 season thank you Mike as always
we appreciate your time all right Dan
Mike Florio pro football talk live on
NBCSN NBC radio as well for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]